-I want to talk about the movie.
-Yes.
-But I also --
You got to travel
a little this summer.
-Yeah.
-You went to Amsterdam, which --
-Yeah, you have a history
with Amsterdam.
-I lived there
for a couple years.
One of the most beautiful cities
in the world.
-It's the most beautiful -
the most beautiful scenery
the most beautiful prostitutes
-Yes.
-I wasn't even on drugs.
-Uh-huh.
-I didn't do drugs.
I was working.
And also, drugs are bad.
And I was blown away
by how pretty it was.
And I did go
to the red light district
just to kind of see
and whatever.
And, you know,
very beautiful ladies.
And there were -- There were
like, two petite ladies.
And I was like,
"You guys are doing it!"
-Yeah.
-Doing it for the sisters!
Love it.
-Very -- Very hard to find
a petite woman in general
in Amsterdam.
Very tall people, the Dutch.
-Yeah.
No, that's why I didn't stay
No, I just thought
it was so gorgeous.
-You liked the canals?
-I went on the canals.
Like, I ended up -- I ended up
like, you know, just for fun
like, videoing the whole,
like, canals
and the scenery and stuff,
as I am wont to.
It was just sort of, like,
sarcastically
going like, "Ugh, God,
it's ugly here."
Like, "How do you people
even wake up in the mornin
and look at the scenery?"
And most people understood
that that was me saying
it was very beautiful.
And there were couple
of Dutch people
who thought I was
being very rude,
and I should go back
to my country.
But then a fair amount of Dutc
people came to my defense.
So -- But it was all
happening in Dutch.
So now I know
the Dutch word for sarcastic
which is sarcastisch.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So not that hard.
-Not that hard.
-So they were going, like,
"She's being sarcastic."
And several said,
you know, "She's just drunk.
So, I also know --
Dronken is the Dutch word
for drunk.
-Dronken, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yes, I've been dronken
a few times in Amsterdam.
You also -- Did you go
anywhere else in Europe?
-I did. I went to Switzerland,
which is, like, the cute--
-It's really amazing.
-The cutest country.
-Yeah.
-Like, I feel --
Like, I'm being patronizing.
But I'm sorry, it's so cute.
-Yeah. It makes Amsterdam
look like a garbage can.
-Exactly. Like, every hillside
was, like, the most perfectl
designed,
like, the cutest,
most amazing --
And I took a friend of mine.
And she, you know,
was, like, very grateful
to be taken to Switzerland
But as we would crest
every hill,
what am I, an animal? I'm no
going to sing "Sound of Music"
-Of course, yeah.
-I mean --
So it was, like, really watching
a test of our friendship,
like, play out on her face
knowing, like, "She bought m
this trip to Switzerland.
Be nice."
But then how many times
can I sing, "High on a hil
was a lonely goatherd"
before she murders me
on this hilltop
and leaves the body?
-It required patience
on her part.
-Yes, God bless her.
-This film is -- It's a little
tricky to describe.
But we were saying backstage
the director, the writer is --
-Yeah. He's like
a British comedy legend.
-Yeah, Chris Morris, and -
-Yeah, Chris Morris.
Yeah, it's --
It is hard to describe.
It's like a dark satire abou
the criminal justice system.
And it really devolves
into, like, a farce,
like, a full Shakespearean
comedy of errors
where, like, everybody's
misunderstanding everybody
And it's a really serious
subject matter
because it's about the way
that law enforcement
kind of uses entrapment
and kind of disproportionately
targets minorities.
But it's so funny, which is no
because we take it lightly
but because Chris Morris
is so good at using satire
to kind of talk
about these subjects.
So a lot of the details
in our movie
are, like, trying
to be as absurd
as, like, hundreds
of these true cases.
-Because you're basically
an FBI agent
who's trying to set somebody u
so you can get the credit
for taking them down.
-Exactly. Like, you know,
everybody's motivated by ego
And, like, I think
that some people
spend their life thinking
that law enforcement has
our best interests at heart!
-Yeah.
-You know.
And it's really
interesting to --
-I thought you were saying
we were motivated by ego,
which I was also down with
I was also going to be onboard
with you, there.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah. Both true things.
-I know you shot that
in the Dominican Republic.
And now you're shooting
in New York, yes?
What's it like
shooting in New York?
-New York has been great.
Like, I can't believe --
I feel very grown-up
shooting stuff in New York
But I will say, like, when you
shoot in a small town, like,
people are like, "Oh,
I just can't go to work toda
or get into my home becaus
they're filming a movie."
Like, "Yeah, whatever you need."
And in New York, they're like,
"I've lived here for 30 years.
Get the [bleep] off my street.
I'm going to do what I -- No."
And we were shooting
on St. Mark's Place
at midnight on a Friday.
And nobody was going
to be quiet for us.
And, like, you know,
there's just guys
walking through the shots.
And at one point,
a guy was walking through
the shot and vomited.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And when
something like that happens,
you realize that there's
no, like, department
for that on a film set.
There's no one whose job it is
to clean up the vomit.
And it was right next to
the director's, like, monitor,
where he's going, like,
"And cut.
Um, some notes?"
But -- So they didn't
have a solution.
So they just set up little
orange cones around the vomit.
[ Laughter ]
But what was crazy is,
I was thinking about it,
and I was like --
It was little orange cones
which to me suggests
that this happens enough
that they have special orang
cones for vomit situations
in New York.
-They have, like,
ones for traffic.
And then they have
little ones --
-They're, like, just for vomit
[ Laughter ]
-It's always so wonderful
to see you here.
Congrats on the movie.